earlier this week new york police
arrested the owner of a bar on staten
island
apparently the lockdown rules and this
will surprise you but hey it's science
only applied in the republican voting
parts of staten island
that was so obviously political the
whole thing
that protesters came you could walk two
blocks from the bar max public house and
he indoors without any objection from
the state health
health department well today the owners
of max public house
met with city officials apparently
didn't go well
here's what they told us a short time
ago
hey tucker thanks for sending the camera
out here to mac's public house so that
we can make an announcement and give
some updates on what's going on
the last couple of days we've been
closed since those recent events that i
was taken out of here
and we've taken a diplomatic approach
we've pleaded with the mayor and the
governor and the sheriff
to help work with us and to get small
businesses open or to assist us in some
way
unfortunately that hasn't happened so
the timeline has ended
and we're here to tell you that max
public house is officially open and we
will not
close talker thanks for having us as
always
as his attorneys mark fonte and i have
advised both keith and danny of the
legal ramifications of their decisions
as a proud staten islander and a very
proud american
i stand and support them
we should tell you that every small
business owner every single one who's
come on this show to explain what's
happening
under coronal law has been harassed by
the state they live in in some cases
arrested a number of cases arrested so
we're going to continue to
monitor what happens at max public house
through the weekend this cannot go on
it's so obviously political it's so
clearly divorced
from science and people are starting to
figure it out but again we're going to
keep you updated on that